we're so excited for you all to check
out this next game
oh neelam i can't wait to get my hands
on this one
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the whole team is super proud of this
new game
and i can't wait for you to experience
it
it's fair to say that we did something
quite surprising with the concept of
mario plus rabbit's kingdom battle
and for this project we didn't want to
stop there
hi everyone mario anderson are back
and i'm so excited to be back as well
today to unveil our new project
mario plus habits spark survey we are
diving back into this unique crossover
with even bigger ambition expanding our
universe
on a major scale this time it's not just
the mushroom kingdom
there is an entire galaxy to save to do
so
you will lead a brave yet reckless team
of unique eels including some fresh
faces
like rabbits rosalina and other
surprises
on their quest to repel evil across the
galaxy
their spaceship will bring them from
planet to planet
they will be facing a powerful villain
cursor an enemy unlike anything
our heroes encountered before
but they won't be alone by their side
they will left their new allies the
sparks
these surprising creatures burn from the
merge
of rabbits and lumas will lend their
wild powers
to our ears their natures
and origin are at the core of our story
but let's keep some surprises for later
[Music]
after the tremendous success of mario
plus rabbit's kingdom battle
the entire team was moved by the amazing
reception from players across the world
we were stunned
by the love we felt for this unexpected
team up
we know we've been off the radar for a
while now as we wanted to take the time
needed
to bring this cross over to the next
level
it's not just a new story with new
enemies new heroes
mario plus rabbit sparks of hope has big
ambitions
it introduces new action elements into
the mix that will push the boundaries of
tactical games
even further that being said we also
wish to offer
an easy to play experience for all
players yet hard to master for those of
you that are willing
to take the challenge and you'll be able
to experience this cosmic adventure
exclusively on the nintendo switch
we can't wait to tell you more about the
game soon
there is an entire galaxy to save and we
cannot wait
for you to experience it
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you